I'm really happy to be able to show you
some of the things that we do and also
hopefully teach you something new about
crowdsourcing and I can try to make a
little bit interactive I'll ask you some
questions but if you if you to sleep
your don't feel like answering don't
worry so my name is machi and i work at
rainforest where we use lots of
crowdsourcing to make our product work
and i'm just curious have any of you
used something like mechanical turk or
cauliflower to get some data some
labeling or something awesome can
someone share like what have you used it
for and what are the kind of problems
that you let you found right right right
so that's not a planted person but it's
exactly the kind of answer that I'm
hoping to answer with with the talk so
the problem was that the workers don't
always follow instructions exactly and
sometimes it's it seems like it would be
faster to just do it yourself rather
than asking other people to do it so I
mean if you still have other problems
i'm really interested in this topic in
general so please talk to me afterwards
and ok so the there are three technical
parts of this talk i will tell you about
the kind of data that we gather and what
we do with it how we model the data how
we kind of understand it and then how we
deploy it how we can actually use our
understanding to make the product butter
and there's also a slightly less
technical parts of the talk about
empathy because as we found out a while
ago there are many many things you can
do to improve the quality of your
crowdsourcing sort of micro task workers
but are not necessarily technical but i
think it's extremely important and also
if you pictures of puppies later on so
the first part is the data and to tell
you what the data is
have to tell you what train for it does
so we basically provide quality
assurance as a service so if you if
you're a comp sort of a modern software
development company you want to deploy
multiple times per day and of course you
have your unit tests but you also need
functional testing and traditionally if
you deploy once a month you have a QA
team that does the whole release testing
before it goes production but if you
want to do with multiple times per day
there's no time for that so right for it
allows you to do this kind of quickly
and get integrated into continuous
delivery and because we deal with humans
we have to verify what they do because
of these problems that's tetra
mentioning before and so specifically um
I just how did cookie describe what
customers do what sort of what workers
do and then what kind of problems we we
expect and we observe so what a customer
do is this they basically right in plain
English what the tester should do so it
says something like go to a specific URL
look at the page and does it look fine
like because it's English and because
humans are reading it you can basically
write whatever you want in this case we
are testing rainforest using rainforest
so we want to check whether our blog is
fine and as does the test that we wrote
is just one step there there can be
multiple sort of steps and then a worker
and get that they get the instructions
on the top and on the bottom they see a
virtual machine so it's a terminal into
a virtual machine with the sort of the
right browser version and so on that
that people want to test on and then
they follow the instructions using the
the terminal so the kind of problems
that we might have our first of all the
testers might not understand the
instructions not all of them are English
speakers or native English speakers some
tests are badly written so that's enough
one source of potential problems even if
they understand the instructions there
might be some ambiguity in what they are
expected to do and they might not sort
of know what is the right thing to do in
scenario even if they understand it and
finally they might just not want to do
the right thing they just want to
minimize the time it takes them to
complete the task and just get paid and
this is the thing that we try to
counter enter up any potential solutions
for this as I already sort of alluded to
at the beginning need to make sure that
your work is are trained that you set up
the incentives correctly you can track
the reputation so that to trust people
that you know are good more than new
people you can ask multiple multiple
people to do the same task and look for
consensus and finally you can also
detect bad work from input patterns and
that's the topic of of today and it's
based on a paper from stars in 11 where
they poop proposed this kind of approach
and it's it works well enough for the
kind of data that we capture first of
all as I mentioned everything happens
inside the virtual machine so all the
activities of workers are attracted so
their mass movements and keystrokes and
network traffic and so on and I'm going
to we have labels I'll tell you later
how we get the labels but we know that
for each step as a bunch of activity and
we know there is either lazy or not and
so ah one more thing before this is the
kind of thing that we might see as
admins after someone completes a chest
so this is a login page to reference
with mouse traces over late so you can
see that the toaster clicks on the on
the address bar probably pasted the URL
it's probably some information about
pressing entered and they click on email
address that's and password and then
logged in so that looks like a
reasonable piece of work day assuming
the instructions were log into the
website they did the right thing so from
this kind of data and the until given
the labels what kind of features would
you think of if you just say ok album
which is going to put it into a row for
us or whatever i will need need a
feature vector a bunch of numbers and
you take this yeah time taken
it's it will be awesome to have eye
tracking and I mean it's kind of an idea
that's that I'm thinking of but no so
far we're not doing it so we could just
sort of try to approximate it with the
most races but ya know we have another
church but it's a potential potential
solution yeah right of course yeah so
time between like clicks or keystrokes
and stuff like that yeah so I mean you
you got a lot of it so based on mass
movements you can also look at speed and
acceleration you can produce like
histograms of different speeds and so on
you can see how big the spread is so
someone just clicks clicks and tries to
go to next step they probably have sort
of depending on the task they might have
a different profile and the number of
keys keystrokes like we can look for
special key strokes so if someone is
asking to paste something in we can look
for Come on B and so on and also look at
Network requests because everything's
kind of captured between and then of
course you need the labels and this is
one of the biggest pains of this whole
approach and at the moment o our
developers get an email once a week with
a bunch of links saying hey labeled data
for me and they go to our admin
interface and click yes this is good
work this is bad work and so on and this
gives us enough to to to do training and
and the interesting parts about this is
how to select data points to label
because we have like tens or maybe even
hundreds of thousands of data points
every week and we only have 20
developers and if you ask them to do 10
labelings per week that's already kind
of pushing it so we can only label a
tiny proportion so we started with
completely random selection then once we
got we got an MVP that was giving us
results that we felt were good enough
and then we started doing this split
where we took fifty percent of things to
be labeled still randomly but in the
second fifty percent we took the sort of
the worst offenders the worst work
according to our newly trained
and it was cool because that allows us
to first of all verify whether the lazy
work that's being found is actually lazy
it gets more visibility to to human
laborers and but it also has problems
because labeling data is useful not only
to generate trading data but also as a
measure of health of our system and
because of that we're going back to
completely random selection because now
we have a by example and we don't
actually know well we know stuff but
we're losing an important metric right
so just not about data balancing I mean
you probably all know this but in
general different algorithms do
differently with unbalanced data some of
them are fine with it like if you boost
it's probably okay for some others at
might not be and there are different
different strategies in our case the
data set is unbalanced because majority
of people are actually doing the right
thing and there's only a tiny proportion
that are being lazy so I looked at the
different different strategies and we
actually had some some balancing
strategies at first so there are two
simple things you can do first of all
you can throw out some data so if you
have a bunch of blue points and orange
points and you have many more blue
points you can just throw out some of
them and not use them obviously the
disadvantage here is that you've spent
all this time labeling your data and now
we're throwing it out so that's it's a
bit painful there's also super sampling
where you can do kind of the opposite
and you can just duplicate the orange
points and there are different
strategies into duplication you can join
interpolating can sort of try finding
clusters and then stop something by some
like cluster centers and all this kind
of stuff but just try being naive we
kind of continuously reevaluate our our
pipeline and with some point found that
section we don't need balancing if we as
long as your metrics are good so you
don't don't just use plain accuracy like
precision recall or balanced accuracy if
your pipeline works with no balancing
that's probably fine but I mean it
depends on the scenario it's just
something worth thinking about so our
model is a binary classification one
more forest it's pretty straightforward
it takes a bunch of these features that
describes and has
bunch of labels we get training and
that's fine except now we have this
classification per step so when I showed
you this example there was just one step
go to websites see if it looks ok but
there might be multiple steps like login
create an account create your public
profile or something it is each of these
is a separate step and we get
classifications per step at the moment
which is not ideal because we actually
care about the whole job so we have a
second classifier if you just don't have
enough machine learning then make make
more pacifiers and that takes output
from the first one and then just some
aggregation and some additional features
on that and then gives you a label for
the whole job and they're probably
better ways of doing is but for us it's
important to be kind of flexible and to
be able to change things quickly so for
now we trust the step classifier we
don't quite trust this one yet and
there's a nice analogy of the whole
agile methodology so do too if you want
a vehicle to travel instead of like
designing a car from scratch though the
skateboard like put some stick some
wheels to the board and you have you
have a starting point and you can build
a bicycle and the motorbike and so on so
that's what we have for now but there
are probably smarter ways of doing the
same thing probably going from all these
primitive features stretch to
classification of the whole the whole
job ok so does deployment a while ago i
thought i had my ipad notebook and I
have my casa fire and had good enough
performance and I thought great um so my
work here is done but then people said
ok it's awesome let's let's just use it
and like how do you do that you can just
ship and I Python notebook and and hope
for the best so what we needed was some
kind of micro service who didn't want to
put it in our main application so we
need to be able to accept some HTTP
request process the data I get the
classification and we turn back a bunch
of JSON it should be sort of fast enough
and we also want to be able to tell
which model is being used at which time
so we sort of retrain every softened and
if you were trained you might iterate on
features you might change the feature
vector as and that brings a bunch of
problems if you do it's Navy in
particular when you think about changing
a feature vector you might make it
shorter or longer and then if you use
wrong your code needs to match the
classifier so if you use the wrong data
for the wrong model you will get an
error but even worse if you change your
feature vector in a different way that
semantic meaning of the feature changes
but the former doesn't you might still
get a number but it will be wrong so we
want to avoid this kind of stuff so as I
said we have my own application
communicating with the with our
prediction service there's also a
database behind the main application and
that's basically all you need for the
day-to-day operation but for training it
probably want something else because
otherwise would have to send a whole
bunch of data and through indirectly and
that might not be ideal so we might want
to do that but don't do that because I
mean it's kind of general good practice
for creating microservices to never have
two different applications talking to
the same database because then if you
change end up changing the schema you
have to update two things at once and
it's just the world of pain so there are
different ways of doing it but we
decided to do something really dumb and
we just train locally like if we had to
retrain multiple times per day that
probably wouldn't work to once a week
once a month depends it's completely
fine to switch will get a dump of the
database or connect to it just right so
we have an ID I put your class because
it's really nice and easy and we start
accepting requests a bunch of JSON data
transformed into number i pass into your
socket learn estimator and then get back
transform back to Jason return do you
know what this is it's a pickle so the
question is in all this pipeline like
HTTP requests to suck it down and back
you need to have the socket learn I
could train estimator in memory and how
do you do that you could do pickle but
that's usually not a good idea first of
all like
ja blip might be better for this
particular scenario so job lip is
something that's shipped to a circuit
then and it's just very efficient at
serializing amp a race so it's great for
classifiers but there's a like a whole
bunch of non implicit assumptions that
you're making when you use pic like
pickle because and there's a great talk
from pike on 2014 if you're interested
in that but basically the arguments
against a job lip and pickle are kind of
the same and that it's difficult to add
versioning and you have kind of you
don't directly control how it's being
serialized and also if you try to
deserialize untrusted pickle don't do it
it's basically we released a remote code
execution so you have to be really
careful so and additionally if you look
at second learning supplementation it
tells you how to do these kind of things
so it says that it's good to not only
civilized the train classifier but also
the data the region packages that you
use with it performance numbers and so
on so then when you when a new version
scikit-learn is released they are not
necessarily backwards compatible so you
can just retrain and get a new
classifier without figuring out which
data that i use for that the you know is
it still performing well and so on yeah
so that's that's why it's important to
keep track all this edit of all this
additional metadata and that's also why
we read this tiny package called
estimator like described estimator and
just you give it a classifier with all
this metadata and it figures out a bunch
of things on its own and then gives you
zip file that you can put on three or
wherever it's not perfect it doesn't so
doesn't do anything to solve the
security concerns so you still have to
make sure you only deserialize trusted
things but it makes something a little
bit easier yeah and it's it's only
basically it's only being used for by us
at the moment is at least as far as I'm
aware if you would like to use it and
you need anything please let me know and
I'm really happy to to make it better to
make it more general and okay so the
other part of the talk is how to make
sure that your work is I
doing the right thing without being this
bad cop and trying to catch them and
banned them from the system by the way
the pet projects for this classifier for
us was robo curve like this robot that
tries to find what people and eliminate
them but then we realized that it's a
bad way of thinking about it and we do
this instead and so first of all if you
do any kind of if you request work on
mechanical tracker spend some time doing
it yourself because it gives you so much
insight into like how your tasks are
listed and twitch tasks are more likely
to be taken and which titles are
appealing and all this kind of stuff so
that's that's really critical also the
people ways to talk to you so it depends
on what you doing but in our case we
have we've been using mechanical check
for a few years now and we have kind of
reputation with the workers they kind of
know as they know that rain forest gives
sort of tasks quite often so I can rely
on them and so on and it's really
important to foster a community and to
actually give people ways to ask
questions they might be well-intentioned
but if if you suck at training them they
was to do it wrong thing and it's not
their fault and finally puppies as
promised this is my dog she's called
whisky and she's a border collie and
that was a few months ago she's seven
months old now but the reason I'm
showing in that is when I got her so but
I collies are released my dogs and I
really kind of their fun but if they
poured they will get distracted so we
need to give them stuff to do so before
I got there I started watching YouTube
videos on how to train your dog and kind
of different tricks and so on and one of
the things that are really cheesy but
really stuck with me is this idea of
setting them up for success so if you
have your small dog and you will new
training them to do something let's say
you want to train them to come to you
and cold you shouldn't start with having
the dog like 100 meters away and then
expecting it to country because they
won't know what to do be really close
and say just make a gesture to make it
really obvious and they'll come over you
give them reward and repeat this many
many many times once they muster that
you take a step back increase the
distance Angeles over and over and
eventually they learn the difficult
thing and but it's kind of the same with
humans I mean teaching humans is not the
same as training dogs but some of the
same principles apply I know that when
I'm learning something it's much easy
to kind of deep learning like if you
understand little bit about sigmoid
functions and how big propagation works
it kind of take it step by step and then
you get to the whole idea but if you
read I know one of the classic paper
straight away with not knowing nothing
before you're not going to have a very
hard time getting getting it so that's
basically what you have to do with focus
oh and this is with you more recently
she managed to successfully shred my
banking bills good luck right so set
people up for success have some kind of
training regime to end monitor how they
do and yeah teach them to do the right
thing to do that you need to have clear
rules which is not always easy even like
it even took us a while to figure out
what it actually is we want people to do
and how to behave and all different
scenarios communicating it is even more
difficult and then basically treat
workers as not as commodity but has a
community as a bunch of few months that
you can communicate with and train them
and you can do all these things that you
do for customers like lifecycle emails
and analytics and all these fancy things
that are actually really useful and
given a feedback and listen also true to
what they have to say and also some
overall limitations of what we do so
data capture most of time works but
sometimes it doesn't and obviously if it
doesn't our classifications are wrong
and just lots of effort in labeling the
data so there's probably something smart
could do like active learning or maybe
super semi-supervised to make sure that
we're labeling the optimal set but then
again we get into this problem of not
having reliable analytics and we could
also do this metal thing which will
build a system for workers to verify
work of other workers and that'll be
pretty awesome but it also has a bunch
of trade-offs and problems that we have
an ear to figure out and yeah this it's
a great approach and you should
definitely do it but think about what
you want to do first if you start with
there are things that you can probably
start with this will give you much more
payoff for sort of more bang for the
back and this is basically as ml is
still useful and it's an amazing tool to
to solve her problems but don't always
jump to it thank you right so I I don't
know open source solutions another's why
hatch is a company that provides this
kind of service I haven't looked into it
that much but it seems like yeah there
should be something like this i'm not
aware of it like deploying maybe not
more little bug yeah so that's tomato
juice thing that we have is open source
so you can upload it basically you give
it a it is only this realization okay I
mean we can think about it if if people
think it's useful I'm definitely up for
doing it it seems like it's maybe not
that it's useful because the other parts
are it's basically a flask API
initialize model and then put numpy data
into it but yeah oh well considered
where did you get your initial we just
got us from humans so from our
developers I mean we used to do it even
before we started this whole machine
learning thing just to just for
verification just trying to catch bad
workers and basically prevent them from
working friday and so when we started
this already had a little bit of data
what we need is more to ya to make it
work well alright so good question I
think it's about well last time I looked
a little spoils we were still doing the
balancing thing it was about 100 to 1 so
about 100 good work good work samples to
1 bed1 but it probably changes because
we also iterate on on the training and
like it changes over time but it's
something i should actually know that's
a good question its kind of undefined
problem so we don't do well on off that
pretty unfair because for example there
might be some problems with our virtual
machines they might not be able to
connect and then they just failed a job
but is again not their fault so we try
to be kind of lenient and we have like a
sliding window and if they cross some
threshold of badness in this window then
they get banned but then they can also
talk to us and they say hey I think I'm
goes band unfairly so then we can look
at it and verify so that I mean there's
lots of lots of work involved in in
talking to them but it's important to
sort of to be strict but also to be
fired
yeah not directly like we didn't make
any code changes yet but we I mean we
definitely started thinking what workers
differently so we still like that the
moves for like Who to allow to work and
I have to prioritize we get work that's
not the same but we are now doing a
better like part of the training is also
evaluation and put a new training we
have a better way of giving people sort
of checking tasks and from that
computing reputation and from that we'll
be able like we have a new way of of
evaluating goodness but we're not using
a chess because it was Tony some some
pieces to fall in place but yeah it's
definitely a working process sure yeah
so there's like a Facebook group where a
bunch of workers are there with some of
our community managers and they talk to
each other and I mean even before we
told them they figure out the star
because they're pretty pretty nifty I
wouldn't say there's more but it's
definitely a big concern writing good
tests is a nice and it's something that
we have a pretty big sort of customer
success story going on because we need
to work with with our customers and
teach them how to how to do the right
thing if you write your two it's just
like Casa fication if you give it bad
data Oh get rubbish results and if you
write your test badly you'll get rubbish
results as well so it is very important
yep
sure so to answer the first question no
there isn't yet but we're working on it
so the we have to be careful because the
we don't want to encourage people to try
to for example keep finding new bikes if
we started paying them like a bonus
every time they find a bug they might
just find period bags that our customers
don't want to see and if you put
rainforest in part as part of your
continuous delivery thing having bugs is
really I mean it's better than not
finding bugs but having experienced back
is also really knowing because then you
have to restart your build and okay
delay the release so it's a very
delicate balance but we definitely want
to do something something with rewarding
workers who who you know are good and
which was and a second so what was the
second question all right yeah so we're
also experimenting with with different
payments yeah thank you so much